Thầy độ phần đất ngận sét đề thì thử sử dưng bình lên bà
mức độ khá rống đề chính thức hai gình không chăm thầy lên.
Thì vừa trở sáng ghiêm đề sử dưng bình lên bà
và thuy nhất là chúng ta đánh lắm một cái đề này
xíu đưa, nó ai xíu đưa
Cách cách kế nước của của của mình này trong mẹ hà của đồ tiền nó vẫn đã cấp miếng được của hòi
ở toàn là miếng được của, kếm gì đây, bây giờ mình được được tiền
nó là miếng được, nhưng là tất tích phần ABBA
Mình được thứ hai là cái miếng được, nên quan đến cái, cái vẽ tất chỉ phương của đường thạm đây
thì người ta cú tình cái đảm muốn chuy nghĩ, mình em ở bà đồng chưa đổi ở năng ngon game
rất là tiền thầy, đứa phải khi trọng ngắn đây